معنا النهارده ضيفنا دكتور حاتم 60 اا
طبيب البيطري زي ما ذكرتي وعضو الاتحاد
الدولي للخيول واهم حاجه طبيب الرحمه صباح
الخير يا دكتور حاتم على
المقابله الجميله دي واا طبعا ولا طبيب
راح ولا حاجه
ومعنا ليلي على فكره ليلي اول واحده يعني
واحده من الناس اللي انقذهم دكتور حاتم
قبل لاول مره
ههه بيسلموا عليك يا ليلي في الاستوديو
ههه
الجمال ده
ههه ايه الجمال ده دي حلوه قوي كده ليه
احكي لنا بقى قصه شغفك
بالخيول بدا ازاي
يعني
كانت بالنسبه لي عارفه كل طفل بيبقى عنده
حلم كل طفل بيتخيل البطل بتاعه
حاجه معينه انا كان بطل بتاع الحصان
بس كان حلم بعيد المناري يعني ما كنتش
اتخيل في يوم من الايام ان انا هابقى
البولف قوي او بقى متداخل قوي معهم بالشكل
ده ولكن الحمد لله
طبعا دخلت كليه طب بيطري
وبعد ما دخلت كليه طب كان المفهوم ساعتها
ان الطب البيطري ده يعني يعني كانت في
الوقت ده ما كانش احسن حاجه ان انت تدخلها
كلمه بقى دكتور بهائم وانت والتريقه
والكلام ده كان كان يعني ما كانش عندنا
ثقافه
احترام طبيب طبيب الحيوانات بالشكل اللي
موجود عليه حاليا الحمد لله
فدخلت بس يا حبيبتي ثانيه يا حبيبتي
يعني مش قادر اوضحها لحضرتك بس يا حبيبتي
بس خلاص خلاص
هي الخير لها لغه الحقيقه مش هيفهمها غير
اللي بيعيش في السرخيل كثير اللي بقيت
عايش معهم بيتكلم نفس اللغه بتاعتهم انا
بقى بيني وبينهم بحس ان انا جزء من القطيع
يعني فاحس ان انا والخيل على طول بيننا
لغه اتصال جامده جدا ممكن تقولي ممكن
تقولي جزء منها موهبه ولكن الاكثر هو
تعايش
الرحمه حاجه بتعمل ايه بالضبط
والله انا طبعا الحمد لله وصلت في ال- اا
في الطب عامه طب الخيول يعني للطوب ليفل
كبروفيشنال ليفيل الجزء الاحترافي
حكمت بطولات محليه عالميه كتري ااا كنت
مسؤوله عن خيل من اغلى الخيول اللي موجوده
الحمد لله في مصر والعالم العربي وبعدين
صعب علي قوي فكره الخيل لما بتترمي في
الشارع الكارو والتعذيب والكلام ده فقلت
انا هاسخر جزء من حياتي ومن داخلي للخيول
دي وبدات بقى ايه اي حاله استغاثه في
الاول ناس كانت بتبعث لي عشان دكتور معروف
في مجال الفروسيه
وبعد كده لقيت نفسي ربنا بيفتح علي
وبيكرمني جامد جدا مع اول حصان جبته فقلت
لا ده الموضوع كمان فيه خير في الدنيا
وخير في
الاخرهم
بس يا حبيبتي
[موسيقى]
او يحصل له اي نوع من انواع الاصابات
والحصان الحقيقه والله باجيب بعض الخيول
الجلد بتاعها بيكون بيطلع كده زي الورد
فا ازاي في بلد فيها بني ادمين العاديات
الخيل اللي ربنا كرمها اكرم مخلوقات بين
الحيوانات ااا يعني مكرمه في جميع الاديان
والرسول وصى عليها والقران وصى عليها
فازاي ان يحصل فيها كده في بلد فيها ان
يموت من الجوع والعطش تحت اشعه الشمس
من الناس اللي انقذهم الدكتور حاتم ايوه
طيب سمر ايوه
[موسيقى]
دكتور حاتم يعني طول حديثه معك
اكثر من مره عم بناديه حبيبتي فانا لاحظت
انه افضل دواء يعني مش بس للانسان حتى
للحيوان على ما يبده دواء نفسي الكلمه
الحلوه هي احلى دواء وهذا هو اللي عم
يعمله دكتور حاتم صح
دكتور حاتم بيقولوا في الاستوديو ملاحظه
ان حضرتك
بتدلل ليلى تقف الكلام طول الوقت وبتنده
لها الحاله النفسيه للحصان دي مهمه
نفسي دلوقتي على قد ما انا هي عندها باور
جامد دلوقتي وعايزه تنطلق بتقول لي يعني
الجو جميل وفي نسبه هواء ساقع انا عايز
اجري فانا باقول لها بعد اذنك هنخلص
وبعدين ده الاتصال اللي حصل يعني اه يعني
باقول لها خلاص اهدي يعني شويه هنخلص طبعا
الخيل حصان
ليه نحكي لي عنها قبل ما نخلص هتلاقيها
فين وعملت معاها
يعني كانت معذبه كانت مستهلكه صحيا خاسه
خالص رجليها وجعاها جسمها وجعها ودلوقتي
يا بطله فروسيه يعني دلوقتي دي يعني
بتنط حواجز وبتعمل كل حاجه ولكن ريسنت ليه
حصل لها اصابه بسيطه في رجليها ثاني بس ان
شاء الله تتعافى لان هي مكافحه يعني
همم وان شاء الله عايزين نعمل معك لقاءات
كثير
لكم همم دكتور حاتم طبعا البرنامج
شكرا لكم صباح الخير يسعد صباحكم شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]